welcome to this video rice steel rice
steal from the UK and I'm keeping this
on this modern defense stuff trying to
get some unbalanced positions okay wise
can write and trade now only five but it
doesn't okay maybe try form some dark
square could roll with night a six this
is quite comparable to UM toward the
Trojan system or some other Kings Indian
line I wonder if I can't play at five in
Viet lame okay let's try that it's
probably a bit risky but if it works out
all right I would have a very nice
souped-up Kings Indian can maybe take 95
have this kind of thing Knight f6 96
okay f5 is a somewhat shocked move but
it can be quite rewarding if it's not
getting blown out of the water quickly
like this yeah with 96 but i was
thinking i can take e 4 and then 95 and
i will get this one only 60 let's go for
that
interesting Jim be four maybe yeah how
to play that without cancelling so let's
do it right away yeah I think I should
do this right to after night age 3 which
I think he should do I mean I t6 I think
i will take play nazi 5 and win the pawn
i doubt that he has enough compensation
then today i was thinking at not g4 is
quite ok preventing Bishop e3 which is
important and freeing this this Bishop
right f2 we as this as possible can take
it I can play h5 maybe h5 that's
actually interesting night h3g five now
as possible but my night on G who is
also very annoying for him yeah and this
okay this is some not very desirable
from a structural point of view with
this age phone booth possibly coming oh
wait I don't need to do that actually I
can also pile up yeah I can also pan up
on the gym I'm blundering age five what
am I doing here I have to have to keep
h5 here oh wow great yeah I can't play
Bishop de for now winning an exchange
but this looks like total insanity
that's too stupid iam it was a good
structure with with I with age four
he's good Queen g6 as well yeah this is
terrible okay maybe a root page six and
hope for the best I really hate that
yeah you blunder one pawn and it's the
whole position it's not like just a pawn
and you continue it's just like
completely winning everything every that
it's that it means against good play
you're just resigning her basically I
take it for Luke edge form maybe I don't
know the only way to get something is
him blundering something who endlessly
stupid sort of what I did he has to do
the same thing to help me now but maybe
maybe there is some Holbrook aveda for
whatever
ok
sure I cannot really take here as it
would drop f5 and do I want to take be
too not really
yeah I don't know what to do really it's
it's just just was just really bad him
okay maybe if I get in the ship to e5 &
F for Alice this could be very faint
hope but but some precise play you
should certainly have a close to winning
advantage ok is just taking of them ok
we should be 4i have bishop d phi m this
blunder stuff
uh-huh
54
should you son ever take it how bad is
it really am but it's probably pretty
bad maybe three is the problem here they
don't have any any tricks there after
Bishop e7 yes Bishop e6 check that's
just not good and I don't know hoping
form play on the dark squares now Bishop
d7 Bishop c7 Bishop Bishop 6 checking g7
captures on a five and then III yeah
something like that on the dark squares
it should be seven what so here time
morning splaying 447 here looking for is
something not even able to just give up
an exchange yeah thats it's really the
problem
amazing
I shouldn't ever take on c4 which is
really important for Bishop b3 is there
a way to do something I would Henry must
put it on before I this bishop and then
somehow try to invade I can take the
pawn I'm just gambling that he doesn't
do it check
it's taking a long time here for some
reason Jack doing him check not even
clear to me the whole thing now e to
check this place for fates have a long
time but what is this actually is this
something with the upon I don't know
okeee they can play with p8 still gyuki
aid keep some things under control huh
yeah okay I was I was I am a plundering
h5 is just so at least you but yeah if i
don't do that i just have a good
position here i am i can go both h4n
queen edge was good i was just thinking
okay I can't play Bishop d7 first and
then I decide what to do with I just
didn't see that h5 was hanging there's
the reason why sorry I think why this is
quite a good position is that he with
this he has weakened the dark squares
here enormously so Queenie assets there
very nicely am it's a different thing
then if you would able be able to play
g3 for example sometime you can yeah
cover the dark squares bhatia this is
just quite nice for me like this maybe
here it's not like I'm checkmating Yuma
so it just go in okay position but I
mean this is just terrible terrible I
can't play that I saw that but it is it
is just not not any good yeah i mean you
can even give up the exchange here and
then the dark squares will be a big
problem and maybe I should have still
done that I didn't want to play a
position where I take on f2 and he gets
in Bishop b3 to d4 but maybe look f7 and
stuff is good of course you can always
play this chand and draw am but this is
so not
good one it's a unambitious yeah I don't
know after that I was in bad shape and
maybe I shouldn't have traded I was
thinking that I have some chances with
their forces probably probably in vain
this was very strong this is this stuff
yeah I'm just barely and barely holding
on yeah white is winning area and was
just trying to complicate matters and
add less time the whole the whole time
and then somehow he spent ages I didn't
even realize that I was ahead on the
clock for some time and only then I saw
how slow he really was I don't know okay
well thanks for watching